we're letting the City Council know that
they can't just come in and Trump the
will of the people and that when they do
things that are very unpopular the
people can stand up and say stop I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer for reason TV i'm here
with Don Duncan California director of
Americans for safe access which has done
a lot of work with medical marijuana
nationwide and particularly in Southern
California Don thanks for being here
thank you very much for having me
earlier this summer LA City Council
passed a ban on medical marijuana
facilities can you talk a little bit
about why the ban was enacted in Los
Angeles we've had a very controversial
experience with medical cannabis
beginning in about 2005 of cooperatives
and collectives started to open here in
the city of Los Angeles for the first
time and the City Council was very slow
to react to that and so the number of
facilities in Los Angeles really grew
very quickly so in 2010 we finally
succeeded in adopting an ordinance in
Los Angeles to help regulate these
facilities unfortunately that was
followed by numerous lawsuits filed by
collectives and cooperatives and by the
City Attorney's Office and so after
years of frustration almost two years in
court the City Council essentially throw
up its hands and walked away from the
issue and said we're just going to ban
these organizations and Councilman Jose
Huizar offered the man he was saying you
know it's gotten excessive because
there's a thousand dispensaries and be
too in some neighborhoods and enough is
enough do you think this was
justification for the band while there
are a few that are operated badly or
located in a questionable location that
doesn't really justify throwing out the
baby with the bathwater people in Los
Angeles want medical cannabis
seventy-seven percent of Californians
support the regulation and the control
of medical cannabis a lot of opponents
also say that it's these dispensaries
are just a farce for stoners to get
legal weed and aren't really for
medicinal purposes there are probably
people out there abusing the system but
again it doesn't justify victimizing the
majority of people who are getting real
medical benefit just like the voters
intended people will find an anecdote
one situation where there was a burglary
or a robbery or someone behaving in a
fraudulent manner and they'll say that's
proof it's all all fraudulent we have to
throw the whole thing out and that just
doesn't stand up to any scrutiny like
you said the support for medical
cannabis is really
strong and residents came out with this
petition can you talk a little bit about
the petition and have the referendum was
successful well after the City Council
adopted the ban patience and collective
operators and organized labor all got
together and organized a referendum
campaign we collected 50,000 signatures
in a period of about nine or ten days
which is a really impressive number we
were able to submit those early to the
City Clerk's office and actually block
the implementation of the band before it
even took effect and so that's a
tremendous victory for patients the next
step is for that to go to the voters in
the city of Los Angeles remand ask them
to overturn the ban adopted by the City
Council otherwise they can use the voter
initiative process which is a tool
voters in california also have where
they can create their own ordinance that
may actually and ironically be a
something city council's favor because
it takes the political pressure off of
them nobody can criticize known for
saying oh you did this you wrote this
bad ordinance the voters sort of take
that authority and it's a shame that has
to come into play in our system but I
think very often politicians prefer the
safest route and putting it off on the
people may be the safest route let's
talk about the future after this band
was blocked or at least for now it shows
very strong support for medical
marijuana and also a check on local
government power for now do you think
this will hold or they'll bring in the
feds like other cities and i think the
referendum changes the situation in los
angeles because it really put very
clearly in the public view that people
don't support the ban and so they want
something else so the city council of
course has a choice now to either just
hold off for the election and then deal
with the consequences in march or they
could take this these few months but
leading up to march to do something good
for the city of Los Angeles they could
adopt a new ordinance they could go back
to the table and sit down with advocates
and with patients and try to work it out
and we really would like for them to do
that but if they don't then of course
we're prepared to go to the ballot we're
prepared to repeal the ban and then move
forward we certainly hope that the city
would be reasonable and not bring in
federal authorities or start prosecuting
people indiscriminately it doesn't look
like that's the path they're going down
we've seen a couple of motions passed
the City Council calling for federal
cooperation when it comes to medical
cannabis we've also seen a call for the
police department to coordinate with a
district attorney's office which is of
course a precursor to bringing felony
charges don't they
want to value of the supporters one
because that secures their own
re-election well we would expect of
course that the City Council members
would do what's most popular but
unfortunately I think that very often
what they hear from another community
are people who are dissatisfied and not
people who are satisfied it's the the
neighbor with one shop on each side of
their house or the the community where
they've had a burglary or a robbery or
something like that those are the people
who are speaking up and really drawing a
lot of attention and sort of driving the
agenda right now other complaints that
it was it was supposed to be enacted to
protect collectives and people growing
their own marijuana and it doesn't
include people making money off of it do
you think there's a problem with the
profits that come along with
dispensaries in our consumer society all
the things we need are provided through
the market economy so if you needed
insulin because you're diabetic you
would buy that at a store and it would
be made by a corporation that
manufactures and packages and ships this
to the pharmacy now California law is a
little bit ambivalent on the terms in
terms of profit regarding medical
cannabis SB 420 which was adopted by the
state legislature in 2003 says that the
nothing in that statute authorizes the
cultivation of cannabis for profit
what's really important about that
nonprofit designation is that we have to
remember that just because an
organization is nonprofit doesn't mean
that no money is going to change hands
when patients visit their collective or
cooperative they reimburse that
collective or cooperative using cash or
credit card for the medicine that they
receive and we have to be very careful
about how our opponents spend that issue
because there's no practical way to get
patients medicine through their
collectives and cooperatives without
having money involved in the transaction
so do you think the the referendum
putting this on hold is it is it more
promising than it is negative I think
whether the referendum is a good thing
or a bad thing depends on which side of
this debate your honor but I think on
the whole this is a very good thing
because we're letting the City Council
know that they can't just come in and
Trump the will of the people there may
yet be one more hurdle for medical
cannabis in Los Angeles in 2010 the
ordinance that the City Council adopted
included what we call a sunset clause
which says that if the city council
doesn't renew that ordinance within two
years it would automatically expire
and every collective and cooperative in
Los Angeles should close and so the city
attorney argues now that collectives and
cooperatives are illegal no matter what
happens with the referendum in Los
Angeles our argument is that it's
unreasonable every single milestone of
implementation was missed registration
deadlines a selection of applicants the
vetting process all of that was missed
along the way the city attorney is
committed to the fact that medical
cannabis is illegal and so we expect
some sort of an enforcement action from
the city attorney that will probably
involve civil measures but that's also
almost certainly going to be coupled
with some law enforcement activity the
LAPD perhaps in cooperation with federal
officials going in and shutting down
facilities and confiscating medicine and
unfortunately that means that some
people who are trying to do right and
are trying to take care of sick people
and obey the law or getting a caught up
in that dragnet yeah well thanks for
coming in okay great thank you for
having me friesen TV I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer